AND DR. JUDI FROM THE DOCTORS
JOINS US LATER IN THE HOUR ON
WHAT A DEEP RECESSION COULD MEAN
FOR YOUR MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT FIRST AMERICA AND SHUT DOWN,
DAY 15.
TODAY WE LOST MORE THAN 800
AMERICANS WHO TESTED POSITIVE
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S THE LARGEST SINGLE DAY
NUMBER SINCE THIS NIGHTMARE
BEGAN.
A STUNNING THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS ARE LIVING UNDER
SOME SORT OF STAY-AT-HOME ORDER
ISSUED BY STATE GOVERNORS.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO,
WHILE NOTING THAT THEY ARE NOT
AT THE COVE AT APEX YET, DID
OFFER SOME ENCOURAGING NEWS.
>> WE ARE TESTING MORE PEOPLE
THAN ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
AND WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THAT.
MORE PER CAPITA THAN CHINA AND
SOUTH KOREA, NUMBER OF
INTEGRATIONS WAS DOWN.
NOT MUCH BUT IT WAS DOWN.
THAT’S A GOOD SIGN.
YOU ALSO SEE THE NUMBER OF
DISCHARGES GOING UP.
THAT’S CONSISTENT.
>> Laura: THE NUMBERS IN
WASHINGTON STAY AND EVEN
CALIFORNIA ARE ALSO OFFERING
SOME HOPE.
>> THE SLIDE THAT GIVES US GREAT
HOPE AND UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
WHAT IS POSSIBLE.
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE SLIDE WHERE
YOU CAN BARELY SEE THE BLUE LINE
OF THE VERY BOTTOM, THAT’S THE
CURRENT CASES IN CALIFORNIA.
CUMULATIVE CASES IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE DOING SIGNIFICANT
TESTING.
THE NEXT LINE UP IS CONNECTICUT.
THE ORANGE LINE IS NEW JERSEY.
THE BLUE LINE IS NEW YORK.
THE YELLOW LINE IS WASHINGTON.
>> Laura: WELL, THAT’S
ENCOURAGING GRAPHS IN THE STATES
WHERE YOU SEE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS
IMPROVEMENTS.
TOMORROW IS ONLY APRIL 1ST, AND
MANY OF YOU WANT MORE ANSWERS.
GIVEN THE MASSIVE DISRUPTIONS TO
LIFE, HUGE FINANCIAL TOLL, THE
LOSS OF OUR BASIC LIBERTIES,
AMERICANS DYING, MORE ASKING WHY
THE MODELS FOR TRACKING THE
DISEASE IN SOME CASES HAVE BEEN
SO FAR OFF.
NOW THE FOLKS AT 5:30 EIGHT HAVE
A THEORY.
THERE IS ALSO THE ISSUE THEY ARE
OF UNCOLLECTED OR INACCURATE
DATA TO DETERMINE THE FATALITY
RATES, YOU HAVE TO DIVIDE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED
FROM THE DISEASE BY THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE INFECTED WITH THE
DISEASE.
IN THIS CASE WE REALLY DON’T
HAVE A RELIABLE ACCOUNT FOR THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE INFECTED, SO TO
PUT IT MATHEMATICALLY, WE DON’T
KNOW THE DENOMINATOR.
NOW WE ALREADY KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE EARLY DATA FROM THE IMPERIAL
COLLEGE WHICH THE U.S. AND THE
U.K. WAS USING TO MODEL ITS
EARLY NUMBERS WAS OFF BY MANY
FACTORS.
BUT OF COURSE MOST AMERICANS,
THEY DON’T HAVE THE TIME TO DIG
INTO THE UNDERLYING DATA SO OF
COURSE THEY RELY IN GOOD FAITH
ON THE EXPERTS.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI TALKED A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THEIR VARIOUS
MODELS.
THE MODELS THEY RELY ON TO
INFORM THE MITIGATION STRATEGY.
>> THAT’S WHAT THE MODEL TELLS
YOU IT’S GOING TO DO.
WHAT WE DO IS THAT EVERY TIME WE
GET MORE DATA, YOU FEED IT BACK
IN AND RE-LOOK AT THE MODEL.
IS THE MODEL REALLY TELLING YOU
WITH ACTUALLY GOING ON?
MODELS AS ARE AS GOOD AS THE
ASSUMPTIONS YOU PUT INTO THEM.
EVEN THOUGH IT SAYS ACCORDING TO
THE MODEL, WHICH IS A GOOD
MODEL, THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH,
THIS IS MITIGATION.
AS WE GET MORE DATA AND THE
WEEKS GO BY, THAT COULD BE
MODIFIED.
>> Laura: THAT COULD BE
MODIFIED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
AND INDEED THE MORTALITY RATE
PROJECTIONS ALREADY HAVE BEEN
MODIFIED.
NOW THE DEATH RATE FROM COVID-19
IS LIKELY AROUND 0.66%.
IT’S COUNTING THE MILD OR
ASYMPTOMATIC CASES ACCORDING TO
A NEW STUDY.
NOW PAST ESTIMATES HAD PLACED
THE MORTALITY RATE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 2% AND AN UNBELIEVABLY
3.4% WHICH WOULD BE DEVASTATING.
THEN ANOTHER STUDY IN THE
JOURNAL NATURE MEDICINE BROUGHT
IT DOWN BY ALMOST HALF TO AROUND
1.4% MORTALITY.
BUT IN THIS NEW STUDY,
RESEARCHERS DUG DEEP INTO THE
DATA TO DETERMINE THE TRUE
INFECTION FATALITY RATIO.
THAT’S THE MORTALITY RATE THAT
INCLUDES THE PEOPLE WITH MILD
CASES AND SOMETIMES NOT
SYMPTOMATIC AT ALL, WHO MAY HAVE
NOT BEEN COUNTED BEFORE.
IT’S REALLY INTERESTING.
NOW THE DEATH RATE VARIED
GREATLY BY AGE.
ZERO 29-YEAR-OLDS, .0016%.
AGE 80 AND OF LOVE, IT WAS 7.8%.
OTHER AGE GROUPS IN THERE AS
WELL.
A RENOWNED MATHEMATICIAN QUOTED
IN THE STUDY NOTED THAT THE
INFECTION FATALITY RATIO IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF DATA.
IT WILL HELP GUIDE THE RESPONSE
FROM VARIOUS GOVERNMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITIES
WORLDWIDE.
AGAIN, WHAT WE ARE SAYING ON
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS THE DATA
MATTERS.
MATTERS TO ALL OF US.
REAL FACTS, REAL SCIENCE.
WE SHOULDN’T BE REFERRING TO OLD
DATA THAT’S ALREADY BEEN
DISPROVEN.
BECAUSE THAT ONLY ENDS UP
SCARING PEOPLE AND THEN
CONFUSING A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY DESERVE TRANSPARENCY
AND A FULL ACCOUNTING.
NOW ALSO MY MESSAGE TO PELOSI
AND COMPANY WAS -- HER NASTY
ASSIGNS OVER THE WEEKEND, I GOT
A HUGE REACTION LAST NIGHT.
IT BEARS REPEATING TONIGHT.
WE ALL HEAR A LOT ABOUT A WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH, MOST
EVERY DAY WE HEAR WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHY IS CONGRESS OUT OF SESSION.
DO YOU KNOW THAT CONGRESS STAYED
IN SESSION DURING THE SPANISH
FLU?
ALSO DURING WORLD WAR II.
WE ARE TOLD THIS BATTLE AGAINST
COVID IS A WAR AND THE
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO IT HAS
RESULTED IN MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS LOSING
THEIR JOBS AND THEIR DREAMS.
AND IN AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
BRING DOWN THE CURVE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
COULD DIE TRAGICALLY STILL FROM
COVID.
WE ALL WANT TO SAVE MORE LIVES.
WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN.
BUT WE ALSO AT THE SAME TIME AND
IT’S A HEAVY LIFT, IT’S A LOT OF
BALANCING HERE.
WE HAVE TO GIVE AMERICANS A
REALISTIC SENSE OF ACHIEVABLE
METRICS TO MEASURE SUCCESS IN
THE END.
SO ALL THE GRAPHS, THEY ARE
INFORMATIVE AND THEY ARE NICE TO
SEE BUT WE HAVE TO KNOW THAT
PARENTS ARE ASKING TONIGHT, WHAT
NUMBERS WILL IT TAKE FOR THEIR
KIDS CAN GO BACK TO SCHOOL AT
SOME POINT?
MAYBE NEXT MONTH, MONTH AFTER,
MAY BE IN THE FALL.
WHAT NUMBERS WILL IT TAKE AND
WHAT NUMBERS WILL IT TAKE FOR
AMERICANS TO RETURN TO CHURCH?
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR A LOT
OF AMERICANS TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
CHURCH EVERY WEEK.
WHAT ABOUT TRAVEL?
WHAT NUMBERS WILL IT TAKE FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL, EVEN TO
ANOTHER STATE TO SEE A RELATIVE.
WHAT ABOUT GOING BACK TO WORK?
THAT’S ASSUMING THE JOB THAT
SOMEONE HAD LAST MONTH WILL EVEN
BE THERE NEXT MONTH, THE MONTH
AFTER OR SOMETIME IN JUNE.
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS,
SAFEGUARDING OUR HEALTH AND
WELFARE AND OUR LIBERTIES IS
WHAT ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT, THIS IS WHAT OUR
FOUNDERS UNDERSTOOD, THE
BRILLIANCE OF OUR FOUNDERS.
THEY UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU NEEDED
ALL THREE BRANCHES WORKING
TOGETHER AND THEY SHOULD BE
RIGHT NOW, CHECKS AND BALANCES,
OF COURSE.
WE ALL LOVE AND VALUE THE
DOCTORS AND ALL THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE JUST
HEROES TONIGHT.
BUT WE ALSO LOVE OUR FREEDOM.
AND OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILY.
SO HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT ON
APRIL 25 WE MIGHT HEAR THAT OH,
REALLY NEED TO SHUT DOWN TO THE
EARLY PART OF JUNE IN ORDER TO
BEND THE CURVE EVEN MORE.
WE BETTER GET READY FOR THAT
MESSAGE EARLIER, NOT LATER.
WE SHOULD DISCUSS THOSE METRICS
NOW, NOT IN THREE WEEKS.
>> MITIGATION STEPS THAT ARE ON
YOUR 30 DAY PLAN, IS THAT
ENOUGH?
OR IS MORE NEEDED?
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT.
WE HOPE IT’S ENOUGH.
WE HOPE WE ARE AT A LEVEL WHERE
WE CAN SAY LET’S GO, BECAUSE OUR
COUNTRY WANTS TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
I COULD ASK THE DOCTORS TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
>> Laura: AGAIN, BACK TO THE
LEVEL, THE TO THE NUMBERS.
SPEAKING OF DOCTORS, THIS IS
WHAT SERGEY GROUPED ASIDE TODAY.
>> WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEING IN
TERMS OF THE WAY THIS
INFORMATION, THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE SORT OF
BEEN ROLLED OUT IS THAT THEY ARE
COMING OUT SOMEWHAT PIECEMEAL,
RIGHT?
THE FIRST IT WAS A COUPLE WEEKS
AND NOW IT’S BEEN EXTENDED IN
ANOTHER MONTH.
I HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK TO
DR. FAUCI TODAY, I INTERVIEWED
HIM FOR OUR PODCAST.
I SHOULD HAVE ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
IS THIS PART OF THE STRATEGY TO
SLOWLY EASE THE COUNTRY INTO
THESE EXISTING AND DEEPENING OR
AT LEAST LENGTHENING GUIDELINES.
HE SORT OF SAD WELL, YEAH, WE
DON’T WANT TO SHOCK PEOPLE WITH
THIS.
WE WANT TO AT THE DATA BUT THE
DATA CERTAINLY SUGGESTING IT’S
LIKELY TO GOAD ON BEYOND
APRIL 30.
>> Laura: OKAY.
OKAY.
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
BEYOND APRIL 30.
YOU’VE HEARD OF MISSION CREEP?
WE MIGHT BE LOOKING AT SHUT DOWN
GREAT.
SHUTTING DOWN THE COUNTRY UNTIL
MID-SUMMER?
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE ALL HEARING.
IT WOULD INVARIABLY PREVENT A
LOT OF COVID-19 DEATHS.
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT THING.
SO WOULD SHUTTING DOWN FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR.
BUT AMERICANS, LIKE THE DOCTOR,
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT OBJECTIVE
SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE.
AND WHETHER IT’S EVEN ACHIEVABLE
WITHIN ANY REASONABLE TIME FRAME
TIME FRAME.
AND AT WHAT COST TO OUR FAMILIES
FUTURE AND TO YOUR BASIC CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
THAT SAID, DESPITE THE MEDIA’S
BEST EFFORTS TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT KNOWS THAT THERE ARE
PROMISING THERAPEUTIC THERAPY IS
BEING USED RIGHT NOW.
>> HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, IS THERE
ANY DATA ON THESE TRIALS?
>> NOTHING THAT I’VE HEARD.
THAT’S THE FIRST QUESTION EVERY
MORNING.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVEN’T
HEARD ANYTHING BAD.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE’S BEEN NO
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
I WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE HOPE.
I AM A CHEERLEADER FOR THE
COUNTRY.
SO IT’S EASY TO BE NEGATIVE.
AND THEN EVERYBODY CAN BE
NEGATIVE BUT I’M A CHEERLEADER
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I WANT TO DO A GREAT JOB.
THE NUMBER CAN BE KEPT AND I’VE
ALWAYS SAID, I WANT AS FEW A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO DIE AS
POSSIBLE.
THAT’S ALL WE’RE WORKING ON.
>> Laura: HE ALSO SAID AMERICA
WANTS TO GET BACK, MEANING GET
BACK TO WORK.
TRUMP IS DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING.
HE IS CONSULTING WITH THE
SCIENTISTS, LISTENING TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
AND HE IS CONFIDENTLY REMINDING
US THAT NO MATTER WHAT THE
CHALLENGE, YOU THAT AMERICA IS
UP FOR IT.